Right. Today we're delighted to welcome
Mr. Roger L. Martin to Google. Ah,
Roger is currently a writer
and strategy advisor, uh,
and he's the former dean
and current director of the
Martin Prosperity Institute
and the Michael Leach in Family Institute
for corporate citizenship at the
Rotman School of management at the
University of Toronto in Canada.
Prior to that,
he was at monitor company,
a global consulting firm
based out of Cambridge,
Massachusetts for 13 years as a director
and is ultimately co-head of the of the
firm.
Mr. Martin is a frequent contributor
to the Harvard Business Review, uh,
and was recently placed
third on the thinkers 50 a
by annual ranking of the most
influential global business thinkers.
He has published 11 bucks,
the newest of which she is here today to
discuss titled Creating Great Choices,
a leader's guide to integrative thinking,
uh,
which this Justin, uh,
has been recognized by.
800 CEO read is one of the best business
books in the leadership and strategy
category in 2017. Please join me in
welcoming to Google. Mr. Roger L. Martin.
Thank you very much.
Thank you for joining us.
Oh, it's a pleasure. Uh,
so I'd like to begin by asking you,
so,
so you developed the theory of
integrative thinking 15 years ago. Yeah.
How did the idea come to you and,
and what is it in its simplest?
Sure. Well, in its simplest form,
it is the notion that when you're faced
with an either or choice or it seems
like you can only do one or the other
thing. What I found is that highly,
highly successful leaders take that as
a sign that they shouldn't choose or
compromise. It's their job. They're
leaderly job to come up with a,
with a better answer. And the way
I got interested in it was Detroit.
I was really interested,
you mentioned monitor company and,
and a bunch of business
school buddies. Uh, myself,
a couple of professors thought the world
needed another consulting firm and we,
we sort of called ourselves internally
were sort of young punks consulting, uh,
because all the Mckinsey and Bain and
BCG people were much older than we were.
And I was exploring the question of why
on earth did clients hire us and for
what particular kinds of things? And,
and what, what I found was that they,
they hired us for that
sort of problem was when,
when they were facing a kind of a
big either or choice, it wasn't like,
were we need to improve our marketing
or we needed it sort of, boy,
we can do this. So we're going to do
that. Uh, and, and we're a bit flummoxed.
And,
uh,
and so I just started observing how they
thought and how the most successful of
them a thought and came to this conclusion
that the only thing I could figure
out that was consistent across the
really highly successful leaders that I
interviewed was this one thing.
And,
and the tricky thing was I first
looked at what they did and what I,
what I found is that there was
no commonality in what they did.
I, um, and it was because they had
a completely different context.
So I, and so I interviewed all of these
highly successful leaders, you know,
Jack Welsh and Michael Dale and Bob
Young and, you know, Izzy sharp funder,
four seasons, et cetera. Um, and,
and I couldn't figure out something
that they did that was similar,
but I realized it was so context specific.
And Jack Welsh was an interesting one
for me because early on and Jack Welch at
the time is as CEO of Ge,
he said to all businesses,
unless you're really big,
unless you're number one or two
market sharing in a divest you,
they all thought he was fooling cause
it never happened in the history of Ge.
And he had divested about a third
of the portfolio. Uh, and uh,
but then later on in
his long tenure as CEO,
he basically told his
businesses the opposite,
which is be small.
He said,
do not come to your strategy review with
me defining yourself as any bigger than
15% of your market.
Uh,
and you could ask why.
So those are like the opposite.
Define yourself as small or,
or a a defined yourself as big.
And the reason of course
is early on he was at,
had the problem of having a really messy
portfolio that he needed to clean up
later on. He was worried about growth
and was tired of the jet aircraft.
People coming in and saying, Jack,
we've got 70% market share already.
There's no growth there that yeah,
that might be of a building
and selling engines.
But if you add in leasing
sales, uh, repair,
trading, all of that, you've
got five percentage share,
shut up and get back to
work. Um, so be so, because,
because there wasn't a pattern of
doing something similar, I started,
I started asking him is there a
thinking pattern? And I, and I,
and I started asking them,
what are the five hardest decisions
you've ever made in your life?
And came to the conclusion, uh, that what,
what made them successful
was not accepting tradeoffs.
Just refusing a and saying there's
gotta be a better way. And then,
so 10 years ago you wrote the opposable
mind, what was the idea of that dog?
If it was,
it was to describe that
phenomenon and give examples of,
of highly successful leaders who faced
what appeared to everybody else to be an
either or choice.
And they did something different.
So when related to your, you know,
if the world you're in, Bob Young,
cofounder of red hat
dominant Linux software,
he faced the challenge of are we, you
know, uh, there's two things I could do.
Free software, which is
what he started in, in, in,
in red hat or proprietary software.
And he liked how much money proprietary
software companies like Microsoft, uh,
made, but he hated the fact
they wouldn't give them this, a,
the customer that source code.
So it wasn't modifiable.
He loved the free software part of it,
which is you give them the source code
and they can do whatever they want with
it. Felt that was, that was kind of
better for the better for the world,
a better for his customers,
but he needed the fact that you couldn't
make a buck in it because anybody could
put together Linux, uh, compilations.
And at that point, the way you, you may,
you the business,
uh,
in 1995 when he was making
this decision was to settle,
shrink wrap disks for 15
bucks by mail order. Joe,
what do you do? Free or proprietary?
That was the, the, the choice he faced.
Everybody else shows free or proprietary.
Uh,
he said, I don't like
that. And came to the,
came to the conclusion that
out of the proprietary model,
what he loved was service contracts.
You made a lot of,
you could make a lot of money on,
on servicing the corporations that used
your software with updates and aversion
control and all of, all of that. Um,
and what he liked about free was,
uh,
was giving them the source code that the
clients, the customers could do with it.
What they, what they wished didn't
actually like selling short,
grab this for 15 bucks a mail order.
And so as he thought about it,
he realized, actually, uh,
there could be a way of getting the
thing I care most about, about free,
and the thing I care most about from
proprietary, which was his innovation,
which just say, here's, here's the deal.
I'm going to make this the first
software that's downloadable,
free off the Internet. We
will get dominant market
share, will be the only Linux,
a company that big corporation to
will trust and will make a will.
Uh, create a big service
of business doing that.
That would be the classic
kind of integrative thinking,
a kind of choice that I talked
about in the 2007 bucks.
So you,
you've expounded the theory of integrative
thinking and the opposable mind,
what new value does
creating great choices,
spraying it explains more how so what we,
what we got that mean the 2007 one ended
up being a bestseller and it was all
great and everybody
said, wow, that's great.
That gives me sort of hope
that I can do something better.
But people struggled with, uh, well,
exactly. Roger, how do you do that?
And we spent 10 years after
figuring out what they did,
uh, experimenting with how you
could teach somebody how to do it.
How exactly did they do it and how could
somebody who might not naturally be
great at this or have experienced in
this could do it so that creating great
choices is the,
is the distillation of 10 years
worth of experience in the how.
So it's more like an a manual that
says if you want to do this thing,
if you buy the premise of,
of uh,
the opposable mind and you want to
do this thing, here's how you do it.
Yeah. It's very, very much a how to
think, a methodology of thinking.
Why do you think that's necessary?
Well,
you know it,
I probably got smacked on the head
enough times by my most beloved academic
mentor.
His name is Chris Argyris.
These are the passed away a couple
of years ago after our long,
almost 90 year life.
But he would say to me when I worked
with him was Roger Action and upon which
you cannot take knowledge upon which
you cannot take action is barely worth
having it all.
And what he said,
his criticism of much managerial advice
is the moral equivalent to grow taller,
be smarter, whatever. And everybody's
like, I must tall as I'm going to be.
I haven't trying as hard as I
can, you know, think harder. Well,
I'm thinking as hard as I can,
all of that is not helpful.
So I have a sort of a high bar myself
or unless somebody can walk away and do
the thing I've told them to do,
I might as well not have told them in
the first place. It's just an irritation.
They all, they'll get their
hopes up and be unable to do it.
And so that was the integration when
people said, I love this Roger. Aye. I, I,
I love the examples you
give and I love that goal.
You know,
how do I do it?
So if we look at companies today,
yeah. The way they make decisions,
there are certain best practices.
What in your opinion is, is lacking?
Yeah,
I think most of the best practices in
decision making are closer to worst
practices and best practices to be
honest. I mean, uh, they're, they're,
uh, I think people, uh,
in making decisions, uh,
converge too quickly on a,
a solution that seems fine,
rather than choosing a
stepping back and saying,
I'm going to try for
something better. Um, I think,
I think a lot of decision making is there,
I say here and Google plex to analytical.
Um, it, uh, uh, this great decisions,
uh, our creative, uh, by
their nature. Uh, and,
and so I, I often see people saying,
well, we've got a decision to make.
Let's crunch all the data in
order to make, make that decision.
And what's the problem
with crunching data?
What from what era is 100%
of all data from what era?
Yeah,
the past.
So can you crunch data to figure out
something that has never happened before?
Can you, you know, like, no. In fact,
if you crunch data from the past,
you will convince yourself the future
will be an extrapolation of the past.
And I'm like not the clever guy who
thought this up, right? Aristotle is the,
is the man, uh, in the fourth century
BC who explained this to the world.
And the world is largely
ignored Aristotle, right?
So he explained that there are
two parts of the world, uh,
in one part of the world.
Things cannot be other than they are.
That's what he said. Fine.
So if I fall off this chair,
I won't fall up. I'll fall down. And
even if I do that a million times,
I'll fall down.
That's part of the world where things
cannot be other than they are a,
and he said in that part of the world,
he invented the scientific method.
It was formalized 2000 years later in the
scientific revolution by Descartes and
Bacon and Newton and Galileo.
But he laid out,
here's how you use science to
demonstrate. He said, the Pr,
the unqualified purpose of science is to
demonstrate that things cannot be other
than they are. So he laid
that out. Uh, and he said,
if you're dealing with the part of the
world where things can not be as in,
they are, be scientific and analyze
the hell out of it. That's rigor.
But he said there's another part of the
world where things can be other than
they are.
Like consumers have never ever,
ever used one of the devices.
It's in everybody's hands as of 1998.
Right?
And now they can't live without them.
Well,
that's the part of the world where
things can be other than they are.
And you know what?
The world's first scientist and the most
important scientists in the history of
the planet said in that part of the world,
do not use science.
Do not.
Instead in that part of the world,
rigor means imagining possibilities
and choosing the one for which the most
compelling argument can be made.
Uh,
the world.
Listen to Aristotle about science and
then ignored his warning about the
limitations of science.
So the biggest complaint,
I mean there are exceptions.
Google, apple, Facebook, Amazon.
But the biggest complaint
of fortune 500 CEOs now is,
is I can't find enough organic growth.
That's my big problem.
And I'm more worried about two kids in
a garage who I don't even know exist yet
than I am about my biggest
competitor across across the street.
That in my view is not uncorrelated
with over the last 50 years,
management becoming science
and, and, and analysis obsessed.
Because if you're a science
obsessed and you're,
and you're crunching data about the past,
eight will tell you a new thing
can't happen and won't happen.
The data shows that it won't then two
kids in the garage and make it happen.
Or Two kids in a PhD program, uh,
at Stanford and make it happen.
Uh,
and,
and then all the companies that we're
sure it couldn't happen because science
told them it couldn't, uh, are wondering
what the hell just happened here,
right. Like all advertisers other than
Google or Facebook or wondering like, uh,
you know, what, you know
what, uh, what happened here?
There are analysis showed that what's
happening here could not happen.
So that's a bit of a rant, but
that's, that's, that's my number one,
the number one problem with a management
decision making in the modern world.
It under values,
imagination,
and then wonders why it
doesn't come up with new ideas.
Yeah. I just, I want to pursue
that tangent nationally.
It sounds like you have a very polymathic
way of thinking about business.
Where does that stem from?
I guess,
I mean,
I've always been accused of being as
sort of a business philosopher. Uh,
so maybe it's just,
I've always,
I guess I've always
wanted to understand why,
why business works and how to understand
aspects about business that aren't
readily understood or
are confusing to people.
Um, so for instance, this
one came out of me, me,
he's trying to answer the question of
why all these CEOs who I work with,
because I worked with a whole bunch of
big, big companies, CEOs saying, Roger,
we're spending more on
innovation and getting less.
I can't figure this out.
What's happening?
And then these people who
don't have anywhere close
to the resources we have are
producing more innovation than, than
we are. So, so, so I try to figure out,
figure out mysteries, um, and,
and give people better ways of
thinking about the mysteries of,
of business life. And,
and uh, it turns out,
I think that that to
figure those things out,
you typically have to step outside the
strictures and frameworks that you've
been taught.
So if I tried to solve the problems of
the business people who I deal with by
applying what I learned at a
business school, and I went
to a perfectly good one.
I mean they're all, there are,
lots of them are good ones,
but I went to Harvard business school
and if I just applied what I learned at
Harvard business school to solve
these problems, I couldn't solve them.
Lots of them.
Most of them.
It's because what it seems to require is
stepping outside the strictures because
often the strictures and question,
you know, created the problem in the,
in the first place. So I guess,
I mean it is a good question.
Nobody's asked me that before.
Uh, but that would be my best,
my best guess at an answer.
Thank you. Um, so when you're developing
the methodology for the book, yes.
Did you come across any surprises or
were there any sort of Aha moments? Yes.
The biggest surprise to knock
me over with a feather surprise
was that what figured out,
uh,
by,
by studying all of these integrative
solutions is that none of them came from
the most commonly used approach
to creating innovation.
What kind of piece of paper do you
start out with to get a real innovation?
What kind of a blank one, right?
Get out a blank sheet of paper,
throw out everything that you know and
that'll give you the best chance of an
innovation. It's a cool theory,
like it makes a whole lot of sense.
You're unconstrained and did the
DA, all that, all that stuff.
It turns out that in no case of any highly
successful leader who came up with an
integrative decision that I studied,
it doesn't mean they don't exist,
but I couldn't find one
actually came about there.
They're innovative breakthrough
idea from a blank sheet of paper.
They came to it by mining opposing models,
so Bob young would say I needed to
have a true understanding of the free
software model as it existed in 1995 and
a real understanding of the proprietary
model and why it was successful to come
up with a solution and that solution.
As I say it, my definition of integrative
thinking is when faced with a,
with a opposing models that you've come
up with a creative resolution of the
tension in the form of a model
that contains elements of each,
but it's superior to both.
And so that you can knock me over with
a feather because up til up until the
time when that became evident to me,
you know, I just said, hmm, interesting.
I was in the camp. Have to free
yourself up and be more innovative.
You get take up blank sheet of paper now.
Now instead what I say is
you have to fall in love.
Absolutely fall in love with
the two models sequentially
fallen in love with the
first one. And the cool thing about the
first, you know, falling in love is right.
What happens when you fall
in love with somebody,
you accentuate all their good things and
focus entirely on their good things and
act as if nothing else in the world exist.
Do we do we all recognize this?
We've all fallen in
love. Okay, so it's cool.
And so I say do that because what
matters is mining each model for the good
things. Forget about the bad things.
Who Cares? Who Cares about that?
You don't want any of those many ways.
So don't even think about them finding
good things and then forget about it and
fall in love again with
the other model and,
and figure out what are the good things
there and then figure out a time or way
to put them together.
And in doing this and doing this,
what we learned just through trial and
error is to push the model's farther
apart to the absolute
extreme. Uh, you know,
so if you're gonna, if you're gonna say,
oh, we have a problem with is should we,
uh, you know, leadership development in
our company, should we centralize it all?
And you're right in, Eh, you know, here
or decentralize it around the world,
people would be inclined to say,
well,
a more centralized or less
centralized model is, let us
look at those two. No, no,
no, no, no, no. Model one,
every last single thing and
decision is made centrally.
There is no central training function.
It doesn't exist.
It is completely dispersed.
If you do that,
you have a better chance as it turns
out of coming up with an integrative
solution, then more sensible.
Yeah. Kind of sensible models. Uh,
somewhere in between.
The reason is there's not as many raw
materials in those compromise he type
models because the enemy of integrative
thinking is compromised. Hate it.
Worst thing, nobody's happy. Everybody's
got to like medium sad, right?
Nobody's like Super Mad and
nobody's super happy. I hate that.
I want delirious this and that.
Turns out for that.
That was another thing that was a
surprising fine. The other thing is,
and the thing is kids
can do this. Uh, we, uh,
we had a great,
a Rotman Grad who was the director,
Dan sort of academic vice principal of
a girls' school, a girls' high school.
And uh, and she said, you know, we,
we want to try this integrative
thinking thing with our great 10 girls.
Those a Ib school, International
Baccalaureate School.
So in grade 11 and 12,
you do the two years of the ID and
so in great to Ng said be good.
It would be good saying, uh, to do, uh,
for grade a grade 10 girls in the spring
of grade tend to be ready for granted.
11 and 12. I said, okay, you
know, I'm game for anything.
Taught them integrative thinking.
Cocurricular was, you know,
outside school for noncredit 22 girls,
they're all keen on it.
Gave them a project similar to the
project we gave the Mbas and their answers
were every bit as good as the Mba answers,
which,
which gifts you, I mean, like that sort
of, whoa, wait a minute. So the Mbas have,
have at least six more years of
formal education read 11 grade, 12,
four years of Undergrad.
And some of them all already have masters
or PhDs before showing up at minimum
of six and they have four and a
half years of work experience.
So 10 and a half years,
a decade of life experience.
And they're no better thing.
So we must,
we must damage them in ways we don't
understand so that they have to recover to
get back to the same
level. But that got me, uh,
which I think is absolutely the case.
And so we now have a huge program
that's the apple of my eye.
I think this is the most important thing
we do for k through 12 and we teach
integrative thinking
now to five year olds.
We teach the content of that book to
kindergarten kids and they're great.
So that was, that was fun. Who Does it?
Who does not get, but there they're great.
They're as good as a graduate students.
Okay.
So yeah, the, it seems
like when we were, when we,
when we seem to think that
there's only two options,
that's something that's almost
conditioned. Yeah. Other than,
yeah,
we are conditioned.
We are conditioned to say a tough guy
or a tough gal when faced with a big
choice like that knuckles
down and it makes it,
the kids haven't been trained that yet.
They sort of say,
I don't like that one or that one much.
You know? And, and if we say, well here,
it would be a methodology for getting
to a better one. They're like,
give it to me. Let's go, let's, let's do
it. Or as Mbas to a much greater extent.
Or like, you know, in
theory that might be nice,
but it's about making tradeoffs.
That's job tough job buck stops here.
Interesting thing is all these
super highly successful, uh,
leaders said,
basically said integrative thinking is,
is, or, you know,
a trade off is my signal to not choose a,
and Alfred Sloan, the legendary
guy who built, uh, uh,
General Motors in the 2030s or forties,
that by far the biggest company in the
world and the most successful automotive
company in the world, it's great quote
where he, where he's quoted as saying,
and this is by Peter Drucker who studied,
who studied him is after a meeting.
It was gentlemen, and because they
were all gentlemen then gentlemen,
I see that we've come to agreement
on this important decision. Uh,
I suggest that we terminate the meeting,
uh, now and come back only when we've, uh,
had time to develop some
constructive debate.
So it made Alfred Sloan junior very
worried and nervous when all of his
executives quickly came to a solution,
uh,
because he just needs it.
We probably haven't come up
with the best one. Uh, yeah.
And, and, uh, and that, that
is easier for kids to absorb.
And for,
for adults stoves or,
yeah. So the message is consensus
is, is actually a bad thing. And you,
you make an interesting point in the
book where you say that a different idea,
even if it's wrong, still has value.
Yes. Could you maybe talk a little bit?
Yeah. I mean, what, what I,
what I try to do now in my,
my life is even when I think
I've got the right answer,
I say I got to try and come up with
a different one, even if it's bad,
even if at the turns out to be a bad
idea to see if there's something I'm
missing.
There's a component that I could add to
my model that is sort of inconsistent
with my model. Like, I wouldn't think of
it on my, on my own. But if I had this,
this other model,
I might think about it like this.
What are the examples we use in the book?
It's the Toronto International
Film Festival, which is
now the most important, uh,
largest dollar volume, more deals done
film festival than any in the world.
Here's handling the director
of it. Loved, loved, love.
The fact that it was a very
community oriented film festival.
Anybody in Toronto can go
and see the movies, you know,
during the film festival,
just to all the movie theaters, uh,
open themselves up to show these shows.
You can buy tickets.
It's very inclusive.
There's no jury that decides which is
the best. Uh, the best film he loved,
loved, loved, all of that. Uh,
but the only thing he didn't like is
that they almost went broke every year.
It was hard to be
sustainable with this model.
And so he looked at con,
which is the absolute extreme other model.
Totally exclusive.
You can't go to con unless you were
invited. And that's because you're a star.
A director of, uh, producer, uh, or,
or the like the show 15 or 20 movies,
and there's a jury that decides who's,
which is the best films, which,
which Pearce says, I hate that.
It's so elitist. It stands for
exactly everything that I stand,
a stand against, uh, et cetera.
But he would be the first to say it's
the only one I studied con that I figured
out the secret to making tiff,
which when he took over was the
third best film festival in Canada.
Montreal was better. Bamf was, oh, it was
better. I was in the, on the mountain,
so it was irrelevant little
film festival. Um, he said,
the one thing I love is the sponsorship
revenue that they get from the global
buzz that comes from
having a prize and heavy.
Who's going to win the Palme d'or that
brings everybody all the stars there,
which brings the media there and they
get all this buzz and then everybody,
you know, Evian or crystal
wants to have a bottle of their,
of their product in front of every starlet
when they're interviewed and it goes,
goes global.
So he couldn't,
what he would never have been able
to figure out. The clever solution,
clever solution for him was,
uh,
what's interesting about the Toronto
International Film Festival to the
industry.
People have to buy their tickets.
And it's Toronto, which
is whether you, you know,
it or not as the most ethnically,
racially diverse city in the face of
the planet, of any consequential size.
50% of people in the Greater Toronto
area have a foreign passport, America,
the highest city in America, and all
of America's, uh, in New York at 20.
So it's sort of two and a half times more,
uh, you know, kind of diverse than that.
So what is cool about the Toronto
International Film Festival audience?
What is it
leading global indicator?
Because the people have to buy their
tickets and they're only going to buy
tickets to the movies that they're,
that they're interested in seeing.
And they are like a little
bit of a, uh, a, uh,
a amalgam of the world.
And so what's the integrative solution?
People's choice award.
How's it about this?
We give everybody a ballot who buys a
ticket and goes to a movie and they will
decide, not some jury of
elites. What's the best film?
And then that film
is probably going to do well.
And so over the last 10 years,
the average global box offer office
of the palm d'or winner and con is 16
million.
The average global box
office of a people's choice
award winner at tiff is 200
million. And those, those last,
those last 10 years,
the,
the tiff films and had 69 Oscar
nominations winning 23 of them con 11
nominations, winning one total
Oscar, and in the last decade.
So what he came up with
was something that made,
made it so that Toronto is
the buzz of producing a,
a place and all the
sponsors want to be there.
And so it's a wash and money
success by being even more so,
it's not a compromise,
it's not a compromise.
He made it even more inclusive. Not only
do you get to go to any movie you want,
whatever you with your vote help
to be the global arbiter of,
of a, of tastes. And whoever wins.
Now that the TIF award in September is
considered the Oscar, a front runner,
uh, in, uh, in the spring.
But he couldn't have come to that had he
not looked at the extreme model that he
did not want any part of,
not quite any part of,
he wanted one little part of uh,
but he didn't know what little part
until he fell in love with that and said,
how does that work? So I'd say that
to any, anybody here in the room,
if there's that model that you just said,
a visceral level,
say I hate that model.
That's the opposite of what I believe in.
Take 15 minutes,
20 minutes,
a half an hour to say how does it work
as it did it produce the outcome it does.
What are the little causal relationships
that produce that, that outcome?
Is there anything I can steal from that
model? So I may still hate the model.
Here's still really doesn't
like can't con at all.
But boy is he grateful to [inaudible]
for having given them an insight that
enabled him to turn TIF from
nothing too incredibly important.
So I'd like to go back to the methodology.
Yes. Could you walk us through that?
Yeah. So the, the, uh, the
methodology is to, is to,
is to first
take them off,
take the opposing models and
push them to extreme. Uh,
then it's to analyze
how those models work.
And again, this is from the mouths
of Babes. What, what, uh, what, uh,
the way we do it is, is layout how
it works. So the film festival,
how does the film festival work for
the various actors that community,
the industry, the festival itself,
and figure out how it works,
what ways does it produce
the benefits that it does?
And out of the mouths of Babes,
one of the kids we were,
we were working with said, well,
this isn't a pro con chart.
This is a pro pro chart. Huh?
And so now it's forever the,
the pro pro charts. Great.
Appropriate surcharge.
And then ask the question and we lay
out three integrative methodologies,
uh, to, to find an integrative solution.
One we call the the hidden gem,
right? Which is the Bob Young one.
I just want one thing out of this
one in one thing. Out of this one,
I'll throw away everything else. And, uh,
and that's what'll that
totally get me a solution,
what we call that double down,
which is what pierce did.
How can you take one model and push down
harder on it to get the one benefit you
want from the other model.
So you keep that whole model but,
but go take it to more of an extreme.
So he made it more inclusive in a way
that got them the benefit of the other.
And then the third is it something we
call a decomposition, uh, which is which,
which is if you want to use, uh, ag
Lafley kind of creating with colleagues,
creating connect and
develop at p and g you say,
and he was faced with a do either may,
uh,
spend less on innovation because we're
not profitable enough spending like we
are on innovation. But uh, but then
that'll make us less innovative.
Do we spend more on innovation and
just say it'll come, it'll be fine.
That's an either or.
And he says,
it feels like an either or when you
think that it's about innovation.
And he decomposed it and
said, no, no, no, no, no.
It's about invention and commercialization
and invention turns out to have very
little scale benefit.
Being bigger doesn't make you more
inventive, per dollar spent. In fact,
there's more and more data to
suggest that it makes you less.
So something for Google to think about it.
Um,
but commercialization is heavily scale
sensitive. If you're proctor and gamble,
you can get a hundred percent retail
distribution of something almost
immediately, uh, and you know how to
brand it. And you can market it a,
and you get the best advertising deal
deals in industry cause he spent $10
billion in advertising.
So what he said is if I decompose
the model into two pieces,
not innovation but,
and commercialization,
I can apply one model to invention
and one model to commercialization.
And the intervention model is I'm going
to connect and develop. I'm going to,
I'm going to tap in to the whole world
of little inventors and be the best place
for them to sell their,
their invention or license their
invention that will double the pipeline.
So we'll have twice as much stuff going
through our commercialization pipeline
and will, will dramatically
improve our, our, uh,
our innovation. So that's the
third, the decomposition. So we say,
try each of these vectors,
try and find a hidden gem,
try and find a double down,
try and find a way to do a decomposition.
And then the fourth step,
that's the third step.
And the fourth step is to prototype your
idea that we really believe in sort of
the,
the design thinking oriented
rapid prototyping because
you're going to be trying
something new.
Right?
And the tricky thing about new things
when you have to use imagination and all
you have is a compelling
argument is they can be wrong.
And so it's better to prototype them and
also that way you can improve them and
make them better.
So that those would be the four steps.
Take the models to the extreme,
figure out,
do the pro approach to figure
out how each of them work,
explored the three pathways to
integration, prototype your best, uh,
best solution and go and my experiences,
you can always come up with a
better answer and either or,
or just a plain vanilla,
the guy hated compromise.
So you consult many fortune 100 companies
and probably many other companies.
Uh, how is this methodology received
when you, when you approach them with it?
You know, it's, it's received
pretty well. I mean, several of our,
of of my big clients like Dow Jones,
30 size clients are,
are training people up on, on this
and saying, this is how we've got to,
this is how we've got to come up with,
you know, can have better answers.
And to a certain extent, this is how
we've got to deal with bigness. I mean,
there's a challenge to being big and
still being creative and you guys would
know it here. I mean,
um, you know, it, it,
it's,
you have to I think go to more extreme
lengths to continue a culture of
creativity as you get bigger.
And so a lot of these big companies are
trying to figure out how can we make
people on a daily basis be
more kind of innovative, more,
more creative in their work and
not just hive it off and say,
you guys are going to just run the machine
and these few people over there are
going to be creative.
Let's have everybody be creative
and you're in sales, right?
You know,
sales is a daily integrative challenge,
right? You would like to sell them
the most standardized thing for the,
for the highest margin than they want
the most customized thing for the lowest
margin. Right? It's pretty much like,
I wanted it to be perfect for me and I
don't want to pay much for it. Right.
So you've got an integrative
challenge every day and the, you know,
mediocre salesman. I would, I
think either are insistent, no,
it's going to be my way or the highway.
And so a bunch of a bunch of customers
say, you know, I'll pick highway,
uh,
and then you sell some,
or you compromise somewhere on the line
in between those two things you do.
And the great salespeople
are the ones who say,
here's the way to get what you need
and to get what we need integrative,
different, different way. So
I'd rather have, if I'm a CEO,
I'd rather have my
salesforce be creative and,
and bring creativity to their,
to their every day and to say there'll
be bog standard and they'll just follow
us a formula while I'll have this small
other group over there doing all the
innovation. I'd rather have
everybody be innovating every day.
And this is a methodology for
everybody innovating every day.
So it seems to me that,
uh,
this exercise is rather a rather rigorous,
activity, sort of mental
exertion. So how, uh,
how frequently do you use it?
How frequently are you to use it?
And is it something that sort of
becomes more second nature over time?
It does. It does become second nature.
There's no, no question. It does.
But what I say when I say is, is, uh, um,
if you don't have a
hard choice, don't, uh,
youth as the youth as if
this, if like, you know,
nature would you feel some pain?
Nature's telling you stop.
Right. Don't keep doing
that. So do something else.
Like take your finger off
the hot hot stove. Um,
I would say the same thing here
when you feel the pain of Ah, ah,
ah, I don't know. I don't know which
to do because I don't like either.
I would love to see, and everybody's had
a little red flag go up and you say, ah,
this the time to stop and think a little
bit differently about think exactly the
way I thought that has gotten me to this
point. Having of having that conflict.
Otherwise just don't just do
you go about your daily life,
but I love this little red flag. Oh,
that's a trade off that I don't like.
Could I do better? Can I do a
lot better? What would meet up,
pay off to do a lot better and then
take the inspiration, uh, to do it.
Um, and what about
situations where you have to
under pressure,
like very quickly make a great choice?
Can you apply any of the
theories in this book? Tuition?
Yeah, I think so. And we have a great
case in the first book where it's a,
it's a multibillionaire who had
between close of market on day x.
It was like a Tuesday and open
a marketing on day on Wednesday,
uh, to make a decision that it would have
either made them probably a popper or
turned out to make him a billionaire.
So I dunno,
that sounds like a decent
amount of pressure, right?
Um, and not much time, right.
It's between five and nine.
Uh, and he's got to make it,
and I think the reason he's a billionaire
is he didn't compromise or didn't
choose either or he came up with,
with a different answer than anything
that had sort of presented himself.
Or people had said, Gee, Michael, you
gotta you got to decide, uh, kind of now,
now, now, now before the market opens,
we have to have a decision for sure.
Or it'll be,
it will be completely too late.
So I never believe in thinking that,
um,
that you should use time as an excuse.
I think you should just
be realistic. Michael, uh,
needed to have a decision by 9:00
AM on Wednesday morning and he used,
I don't think he slept much that
night. Right? So he said, well,
these are 12 and 14 hours or, or
less. I bet I better, I better, uh,
a better use them. Well, 16 hours,
I guess I better use them well and uh,
and used them so,
so there,
there's eight people I think in the world
and the business world let themselves
off the hook way too way too many times.
Oh,
management would never allow that.
My boss would be so mad. You know,
I don't have enough time. We don't
have the resources lab lab of lads,
just like one list of long, long list
of accepted the managerial excuses.
And I just, I don't accept any of them.
Never have any and kind of never will.
And I have it in my own life. I, you
know, I eat the dog food. I've, my,
you know, my career is
a, is, is a series of,
of making integrated choices rather
than accepting the choices that I'm
presented.
Okay.
So you've had a really interesting
career that's spanned several,
several industries and areas,
I guess, um, private sector,
academia and now consulting.
Uh,
I wanted to zero in on the moments
when you decided to switch tracks.
Was that something that came to you
instinctively or was it more of a rational
choice?
Oh, it's, uh, depends what you mean
by rationality. I guess the way I,
the way I made my first
big switch, which was a,
a decision to switch countries
and take a 94% pay cut,
uh, was, uh, was when the
president of University of Toronto,
who was on the board of a
company I was consulting to, uh,
decided that I would make a good dean
of his business school and proceeded,
he's very persuasive guy, rob
Prichard. Uh, and, and uh,
you know,
he persuaded me now he wasn't dealing
with a sort of a completely blank slate on
that. I, I had always felt that
if you do well in business,
you should turn yourself, turn your
mind to public service at some point.
Public service writ large, not elected
politician. I mean public service and,
and, uh, University of Toronto,
like all Canadian universities as a
public university like Berkeley. Um,
and, uh, so I, so I, I thought
of that as public service. I was,
had been living in the United
States for a quite a long time.
I'm a Canadian as you can
tell about all my weird words.
And so it was going to be public service
back in my whole home country, uh,
because I believe that Canada needed
one great business school and it's zero
great global business schools at
the time. I felt it needed one. And,
and,
uh,
I guess I managed to convince myself
or rob convince me that maybe we could,
we could, uh, do that.
And sure enough, we did a,
and you know, when I finished
that 15 or 15 years later, I,
I realized I missed,
I did some consulting all along the way,
but not much that I missed it.
I love,
I love advising CEOs on strategy.
And so I just said,
I'm done with that. I'm going
to go down to halftime. Uh,
I'm going to run a research center,
the Martin Prosperity Institute
that you talked about before,
or I'm trying to work on this tiny
little problem of how to fix a,
the future of democratic capitalism, which
is kind of fun. Uh, and then consulting,
I'm more, and so there is
what I'm interested in and
worried about the future of
democratic capitalism don't
like the way it's headed. Um,
and so let's see if we can fix that.
And, and uh, doing the thing I love,
which is helping CEOs
have better strategies.
So I've always believed the
guy, I was crazy. Folks who,
who built monitor company believed that
if you make better strategy choices,
you use the world's raw materials,
labor and capital better,
and you make the world a better place.
And I still,
I still believe that if you
make bad strategy choices,
you just waste raw materials, you waste
labor and you waste a capitol and that's,
that's bad. That's not, you
know, not good for the world.
So I'm sort of pursuing
pursuing two loves now,
which is sort of public policy
about something I worry about and,
and engaging in activity that I find
it rewarding and I think useful for the
world.
Okay. So last question and then we're
going to open it up to the audience. Yeah.
Um, what's your, what's your Daily
News Diet and if you, if you,
I'm curious if you,
you allocate any time for people like
Aristotle air or day card and your habits.
I think I have very bad habits.
I don't read much at all and I don't
spend much time listening to the news.
So, because like I, I, I think
so what I do is I,
I immerse myself in a world I care about
the world of business and I try and
solve problems for people in business.
Uh,
and that gives me all sorts of raw
materials to write stuff that I think is
generalized, generalizable, Lee,
useful. Cause people say, how do you,
how do you rate so much Roger? You
know, even when Lou, you're dean,
you wrote all these books, I've written
11 books, you've written 25 HBR articles,
you've written hundreds and hundreds
of other other owning. How do you,
where do you get your research ideas?
And for starters,
I don't think of myself as doing research.
I think of myself as doing,
I like to do stuff,
I fix stuff and then I try to figure
out what I've learned from fixing that
stuff. And then when
I, when I come up with,
come up with a problem in my mind then
and only then do I read stuff that,
that I've been told by somebody or I've
come across that I think might be useful.
So I'm like,
I'm reading voraciously,
everything in complexity theory
right now because I think,
I think we've a problem in the economy
of thinking that we're going to produce a
kind of normal outcomes and
everything is going parade.
What's changed the economy
to make things go parado.
So I've got to read all the
complexity theory stuff about that,
but I don't read
complexity theory and say,
how can I apply the complexity theory?
I say,
how has anybody thought about
it from a different field,
stuff that might apply to
this field, uh, right here.
And then I, then I dive and then I'm
veracious than I have the excuse to read.
And I don't mind reading for some reason.
I don't love reading.
I love writing. I did love,
love, love, love writing. Uh,
and so that gets me inspired to read.
And I think that's a very,
it's like seems bad. It seems bad
behavior to me that I don't read.
Read more.
Great.
Well I think we'll take some audience
questions. I'll repeat the question.
So do you think machines will be able
to think integratively in the future and
are they already doing it?
I doubt they're doing it and
it's part because it kind of,
humans haven't kind of organized
the thinking enough on this.
So I mean the, the, the way I think about
it, and I wrote a book in 2009 on this,
if this, if you're interested, called the
design of businesses is, um, you know,
kind of all knowledge on the planet
goes through through three major stages.
Everything we know now about the
world was once a mystery, you know,
why do things fall when
we let go with them?
At one point it was because of a love
for mother earth or animal spirits or
whatever. It was a mystery,
right? And then, and then we,
when some of these things,
we think about enough that
we reduce it to a heuristic.
So an apple falls in the head
of a smart guy and he says, ah,
there's a universal force I'm going to
call gravity that pushes everything down.
Then if we study at uh,
hard enough, long enough,
some of those things get
reduced to an algorithm.
If you drop an item anywhere
in the world when America,
it accelerates at 9.8 meters per second
squared because America is exceptional.
That's 32 feet per second
squared here. Um, and,
and so it's an algorithm and once you've
got something to an algorithm, you can,
you can,
in the modern era,
this is what's different about the
modern near than any year before is once
you've got something, you,
an algorithm, you can,
you can code it and shove it through a,
a digital computer and
do it perfectly fast,
et cetera. So, so for, for, for, for me,
the enabler for machines to
do things is pushing things.
I call that the knowledge funnel, uh, down
the knowledge funnel. And I don't think,
I think integrative thinking
is a heuristic at this point.
It needs to be made more algorithmic
for machines to be able to do it.
And how far that can go. I mean, there
are, there are some things that have,
that have allowed themselves to be reduced
to code more quickly than other other
things. Uh, we haven't figured out,
figure out a bunch of
bunch of things so that,
so it sort of a dependent would be my,
my view.
Um,
I somehow think that,
that the notion that machines
can get ahead of human beings,
uh, on the distillation of knowledge, um,
I'm, I'm probably, uh,
from Missouri on, um,
but there would be other people who would
disagree and say, Oh, yes, they will.
But that's, I'll, I'll
believe it when I see it.
How do you deal with,
uh,
what seems to be a mutually exclusive
choice where integration is,
it's more difficult.
That's what this technique is for.
It's what for what appears
incommensurable choices.
So I,
I am not a believer that,
that the choices we feel are mutually
exclusive are as mutually exclusive as we
think they are.
They're mutually exclusive only as long
as we think of them the way we do. And,
and,
and one way that causes things to
be mutually exclusive in our mind is
abstraction.
We abstract up to labels that
causes us to believe something.
Two things are mutually exclusive,
free or proprietary as how
can we be free proprietary?
Like it can't bigger, smaller. How can you
be bigger and smaller at the same time?
You can't,
you can't.
But it turns out that those labels often
are abstractions that aren't helpful to
our goal, which is to get a
better answer than those two.
So when I tell people is, is, you know,
don't live in the abstraction,
the answers,
the integrative answers lie below the
abstractions in the mechanisms by which
you get to the abstraction.
Are there areas where this type
of thinking will fall short?
I mean, I haven't seen them yet, but
they're, there may be, uh, once, I mean,
I guess in,
right?
Like in the course of human
endeavors, right? I, I think we,
like, we've manufactured the
world that we, that we live in.
It's not as unchanging as
people think it is. Uh,
and most, most times when we seem
to have an either or choice, it's,
it's a function of
believing in that it is,
and a function of living in an APP,
in a world of apps of abstraction.
So I haven't seen a domain where I can
say, oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. In that domain,
you just can't, it's just, there's,
there's no, no, there, there, I mean,
there are some domains that are tougher
right? You know, wars are fought on,
on the basis of absolute
religious beliefs. Right?
Um, and people could say,
well, you know, those are,
those are, those are the either, either,
either or is there, but they're just,
they're either or is only as long as we,
we produce the either or and we produced
the either or by abstracting up to
things that appear to be so contradictory,
nothing could ever,
ever be done. Uh, I just,
I just haven't seen ones where if,
if the people involved
value at better answer,
not a compromise, a just
plain better answer. Right.
Tiff is more inclusive than when then
that when a fierce handling started and
more important and richer
and has bigger buzz,
then con
that you'd think that's impossible.
How can that be?
Because con is exclusive.
It's a nasty, elitist, exclusive thing.
Well, get below the
label. All right. Well,
thank you, Roger. Thank you
everyone for [inaudible].
You're welcome.
[inaudible].